はい  ジャムカっていうお釈迦様がジャムカっていう人を出家させた経緯みたいな
どうして出家させたんですか？ 悟ったんだからですよ
悟ったということが分かったから
お釈迦様はそこに入りました
ん？何？ ジャンルが悟ったっていうことが分かってなくて
やって お釈迦様が話をしていて
助けてあげようとしたわけですか
全然話聞いてないね うん
だから人の便を食べてた人のところにお釈迦様が行って
その人に説法して その人は悟らせたんですよ
たった一晩で 生まれてから歳になるまで人の便を食べていた人なんですよ
一回でも服を着たことがなかった人なんです
それぐらいひどい性格の人であっても
お釈迦様がすぐ一日で悟りに達するようにするという
お釈迦様の能力のことでもあるし
だからといって甘く見るなよという話もそちらにあるんですよ
お釈迦様に会ったら もうどんなバカでも悟るぞと
そうじゃないんです それもちゃんと業論で
その人はもう前のブッダのところできちんと出家して
きちんと修行した人なんです
そこでちょこっとした失敗が起きただけで
修行は無効になったわけじゃないんです
だから ただこの業にちょこっと蓋がかぶってあって
その蓋を破ってあげたんです
そうすると あの過去のした修行の結果もついてきて
すぐすぐブッダの教えがわかるんです
本人もずいぶん昔聞いたことがありますからね
そこで何のことなく自分にはすごい馴染み
馴染めてしまったんですね
初めての真理をね で 悟り開くんですよ
悟ったんだから出家させるんです
悟ったのお釈迦様の力なんです
お釈迦様でなきゃみんなその人は見放すんです
わかりました？うん  先生よろしいでしょうか
うん  お釈迦様は要するに悟れるかどうかっていうところに全部ポイントを置いておいて
このジャンカさんにしても
新年祝福法要で教えていただいたゴーリカ長老にしても
あまり性格ダンビカ長老
性格は良くないような気がするんですが
そこら辺の 要するに我々なんかは
やっぱり道徳をしっかり守って
心を清らかにして やっぱり心を清らかにして悟りに近づいていくっていう
一つ一つやっていくっていう作業はとても大切だと思うんですけれども
そういうお釈迦様にしてみると
そういう方たちはあまり性格っていうのは全然重視されてなかったんですか
うーん どちらにポイントを入れてるんでしょうかね
質問のポイントはなんですか
道徳と悟りの関係性  俗世間から見れば
俗世間の目で見れば性格が悪い
なのに違いますよと 真理の目で見ると
ということメッセージでしょ
人は表面で判断するんじゃないよと
いうことでしょう だから特別ケース
ケースという名前を残して記録しているのは
全部この大胆なケースだけ
全部ケース残すっていうことはもうもう無茶苦茶量が足らんでしょうに
だからもうものすごい大胆な
もうもう信じられない奇跡的なケースだけを残してますよ
仏教のケースの場合は
だから一つもごく普通ノーマルなケースは残ってない
それは記録にならない
あまりにも大胆なものだけ記録として残しているんです
そういう人も悟ったんだからということで
だから表面的には判断してはいけないということになります
性格が悪かったんでしょうかね
人間っていうのは大体表面的に結構ふざけたことをやっている人は結構いますよ
でも内心はそうじゃないんです
表面的に見る場合は内は腐るんですね
逆に表面的にすごくふざけてもう腐っているようなことをすごく演じる場合は
中身はしっかりしているんです
たまたま本人もわからないんですけど
自分たちは本当にすごい芯が持ってるんですけど
本人も気づいてない それで性格的にはすごく暴れまわったりして
どうにもならんというね
だからまるっきり手に負えない
ものすごいもう鬼やという風な人々でも
何人か私が見たら もうこれ鬼でも何でも悪魔でも何でもなく
こいつはすごい芯がいいんだよと
これわかったらもう一言葉で直りますよ
そこを読めたらもうそんなに難しくはないんです
だからそれブッダのアドバイスは今も機能はしていますよ
だから私たちを私はブッダのただの受け入ればっかりですから
別に それでこいつ この人はかなりもう表面的にはもう社会には置いておけませんよと
もうこのままだったら刑務所でしょうとか思うんですけど
中身見るとそうじゃなくて
すごい芯がある それだったらもうこの上の殻をね
ちょこっと叩いちゃえば終わりと
そこで適切に叩くっていうことは
中にある本心を飛び上がるようにする
それで殻が破れるんです
飛び上がるような何か一言葉言わなくちゃいけない
そういう一言葉が本心に入っちゃって
その本心がドーンと飛び上がってくる
それでもう今外に自分が作っている殻がもう破れちゃう
それで本人も全然知らないうちに
いきなり 1 日にしていい人間になっているんです
子供なんかすごく面白いんです
瞬間でカチッと変わるんだからもう
本人変わったっていうことも本人さえも知らないんで
それからすごくよく何のこともなく落ち着いて生きる
そういうことです 決して性格が悪くなければ悟れませんっていう意味じゃないんです
アングリマーラさんみたいにね 900
人ぐらい人を殺さなきゃ悟れないのかっていう話ではありません
長老様よろしければ 自分は自分はないというか
自分というものはなり方ないということについてなんですけれども
それでは五戒を守ることを止めない私とか
道徳を守ることを止めない私というものが少なくともいないと
悟りを得るまでは少なくとも
意外とちょっと困るのでは
言葉としてはずっと使いますよ
言葉として使いますし
理解もしますけど 中身はないんです
例えば場合によっては
あの人は絶対に汚いことをして人を騙さない人とか
あの人は約束を破るようなことはしない人とか
何々しない人っていう表現をした方が
その人との性格をよく表しているような場合もあって
それで誤解にしても 私は何々をしませんとか
道徳にしても何々をしてはいけない
子供を教える時も何々をしてはいけません
何々をしないっていうことが非常にポイントになっているので
それではその守り その誤解を守り
守ることをやめない私というのが悟りを得るまで必要なのではないかなと
これは人間の脳の問題ですよ
ただ脳で固めて概念作るんですよ
だから誤解を守る私という概念ですよ
それは脳にあるちょこっとした問題で
そんなに気にしなくて
そこでだから実体として変わらない私がいるわけじゃないんですね
だから今 脳の中でもう嘘を言わない私という概念は当然あります
それはただの脳のカラクリで
概念である 別に中身がないという実体はないということが悟りの境地で
悟ったんだからといって
脳のカラクリはそのままですよ
それでも私という言葉を使います
人に見られても あなたは随分嘘をつく人でしょうと悟った人もいますよ
でお釈迦様もおっしゃいますからね
で こっちでも愚か者という言葉で対照ね
だからその人って それはもうただ言語と脳の認識システムだけのカラクリですよ
それで我々はね 人を人を騙さない
騙すことはしない あの人という場合は
ただの脳のカラクリで言ってるんですね
どういうことかというと
頭でケース一つか 2つか入れておいて
それで全体的に表現するんです
だから田中さんは人を騙せませんよと私が言う場合は
私は知ってるケース一つか 2つがありまして
その場合はその人はもう人を騙さなかったんです
それでああ この人は人を騙せませんよという全体的な結論に達するんですよ
本当は厳密に言えば それは全体的な結論に達しません
なぜは なぜならば 田中さんは人を騙せないということは言えるのは
田中さんが死んだ瞬間なんです
もう田中さんは人を騙さない人だというためには
生まれた瞬間から死ぬ瞬間
間で どんな瞬間を見たっての人と関係あった場合は人を騙すことをしなかったと
したがって 田中さんは人を騙さない人でしたとは言えますけど
普通はそうじゃないでしょ
時々 ずっと付き合ってる人でも一回裏切っただけで
あの人は裏切りもんやと決めつけちゃうでしょ
だからそこは我々の思考の間違いなんですけど
俗世間のそういう思考なんで
全然完全じゃないんです
思考はいい加減ですよ
だからそこまで気をつけるということはね
人間にはちょっと難しいし
あんまりも気をつけちゃうと
なんかもう社会ではね
なんか嫌な人になっちゃいますよ
例えば私は知ってる限りは
田中さんは私が知ってる範囲では田中さんは人を騙してないんだよと言った方がより真理に近いんです
それで聞いてる人はややこしいあんたの言葉っていうことになっちゃうんですね
である人とまた同じことで議論が起きちゃって
この人を推薦しちゃって
その人がちょっと問題が起こしたということで
この推薦した人に当たろうとするんですね
なんでそんな人を推薦するんでしょうかと
だから私とその話をしたんですよ
私はね あのね その推薦した人に当たらないでくださいと
間違いだと 推薦した人があなたを信頼できないと思ったら
それは違いますよと でもなかなかもうこの人はもう納得してくれなかったんですけど
私は説明したのは 仕事を欲しいんだから
なんとか推薦状を書いてくれと言ったら
まあ自分が知ってる範囲で
この人はもう頑張り屋で
あの まあ向上的心を持っていて
あの 英語で書く場合ね
まあ一応向上的な思考を持っていて
まあまあ 物事に挑戦する人であると
を書いてはあげる  そういういいとこ
長所あったら長所も揃って書いてあげる
だからといって 推薦した人は全責任とか全然責任持つ必要ないんです
で 私はある人に あの ある人はこの人に仕事をあげてくださいと
もう頑張ってる 頑張るつもりでいるんだから助けてあげてくださいと
保証しますよと そこでそちらの関係で何かトラブっちゃうと
その人の性格の問題であって
そちらでそれを解決しなくちゃいけないんですよ
で だから人間というのは次に何やるかって誰もわからないでしょうに
今まではやらなかった
例えば学校から先生は推薦状は書きますよ
先生知ってるのは生徒ですからね
生徒としては まあ頑張りましたと
社会人になったところで
もう物を盗んだんだからといって
これには先生には責任は持てません
そういうわけで 人間っていうのはもうはっきり何者かということは死ぬまでわかりませんよ
だから固定した自我がないんですね
一応 でも我々の脳ではそんな完全理屈はないんです
脳ではもう全て不完全な理屈で
とにかくこのまとめて一色にするという脳のし-- 怠け思考があるんですよ
なんでまとめちゃうと
例えばちょこっと人が喋っている途中で怒った瞬間
そこですぐインパクト声入っちゃって
あ この人はすぐ怒るんだと
それでもう決めちゃう
一生決めちゃうんですそれで
あの人はちょっとしたことでカッとなるんだよと
そう思ってしまうんです
私も同じこと言いますけど
私の頭の中ではこの人は死ぬまでそんな性格だよと言ってない
時々私に悪口言われたら怒って
なんでそういうことをするの？私は
いえ 言ったのはあんたはこれ直してほしいんだからやと
その性格は あんたすぐカッとなる人やと言っても
あんたは永久的にカッとなるという意味を私は持ってないんだよと
それ自分で分かって気をつければどうでしょうかと
真摯に言ってあげただけやと
ということにするんです
逆に あんた今ちょこっとカッとなったでしょう
ああ まあまあいいやっていうことにしちゃうと
その人はその性格を直さないでしょうに
いいときであんたよくちょっとしたことでカッとなるんだから
もうどうしようもないねとか言った方がいいんですよ
でもその言葉が正しくないんですよ
これ人生全体的にしていってるんだからね
論理的に正しくない しかし
そう言わざるを得ないんです
そう言われると 本人はじゃあ明日から違う人格になるぞってことは不可能ですよ
なぜならば人格というのは固定していない
私っていうのは固定していない
そういうことで 五回守る私っていうことは
その脳のからくりで生まれるものですよ
我々は言語を使ったり考えている場合は
そういう不完全な脳の働きで生きています
だから言語で語る場合は確実に不完全な言葉になります
ですから この宝物のように金言というのは世の中でみんなには言えませんね
ある稀な人々だけですね
金言を言い残すのは そこでブッダの特別なところというのは
言ったものは全部金言のみ
言語を使っているんだけど
完璧に喋るという 例えばこの経文句にしても
時一回草の葉っぱでご飯をなめるだけの愚か者には価値がないと言ったっても
こちらで言ってるのは
その愚か者が真理経験することと比較すると
あの行は何の価値もないんだよと
だから同じ人に当てはめてますよ
だから固定させてないんですよ
見事に 例えばある人にあなたが歳になるまでずっとご飯はもう草の葉っぱでなめただけの生き方をしてきたんですけど
あなた真理を知ったということと比較すると
何の価値もなかったよと
いうことなんです だからもう完璧な言葉なんですね
論理的に間違いあるんだよとは言えないんです
今の話とちょっと逸れちゃうんですけど
儀式の話が少し出てきたと思うんですけれど
先祖供養についてちょっとお聞きしたいんですけれど
この本を読んで 例えば死後どうなるかっていうのを読むんですけど
私の父はもうすぐ一周忌なんですけれども
私の家は神道なのでお経をあげないので成仏してないような気がしてるんですけど
例えばこの本の中でビンビサラ王の先祖供養ということで
お布施をしてこの功徳を先祖に回向しますという風に自分の気持ちでやれば先祖供養になるっていうようなことが書いてあったと思うんですけど
そういうふうな形で自分に例えばやれば供養になって成仏してもらえるんでしょうか
うん  例えばここのあの
あの なんですか あの願望紙がありますよね
あそこに一言書いてあります
誰々のためにとか ああいう形ですれば
うん 一応なります だから自分が徳を積んで徳を回向すると
向こうは期待しているならば確実に行きます
だから成仏してないとかそんなの分かりませんでしょう
結局はね  本を読んでいると
その時の状況って  死ぬ時の状況には大体よります
例えば病院で一人で朝早く亡くなってたみたいで
生前の性格とかちょっとこだわってたところがあったので
多分いろいろ未練とか押し込んで死んでたので
すごく気になってるんですけど
まあまあまあ それにしても
我々には分かりませんということなんですよ
一応未練なく死んだ方がね
一番楽ですけどね それは分からないんですよ
だから我々はそこは別にガチャガチャ言わないで
もうせっかく自分の親戚であるし
両親であるし もう一生懸命お世話になって育ててくれたし
だからそのすごいその感謝を感じて
まあ供養はする 受けられるかないかというのはあんまり気にしない
こちらの責任を果たす
義務を果たす 親孝行する
たとえ受けなくても 例えば生まれ変わった場所がまずくて
こちらでいくら供養しても行かない届かない場所にもいる場合もあります
それであっても 自分が親孝行している
だから徳が消えないんです
自分が親孝行している
自分が人間らしいことをやっている
自分がちゃんと恩返しはしている
だから自分が自分の義務を果たしているんだから
自分の人生は幸福になります
すごい立派な人間になります
ですから 先祖供養っていうのは人間としてやるべきものになっちゃうんですよ
先祖が苦労して手塩にかけるというんでしたっけ
そういうことをして育てたんだからね
そういうことで 人間として必ずやらなくちゃいけないことをやっているということになります
それから我々仏教の場合は
供養する場合はワイルドカードで供養するんですよ
ワイルドカードっていうのはコンピューター用語なんですけど
当てはまる何でもいいんだというね
まあ今インターネットでもいろんな検索するでしょ
何か一言葉入れているんですよ
そうするともうもうもう 1万ぐらいヒットするでしょうね
1万ぐらいのページが全部私に必要わけじゃないんです
あれもワイルドカードシステムなんですよ
例えばネットで腕時計を買いたいと言うと
なんとか腕時計と入れて検索しちゃうと
腕時計という単語が入っているページが全部出てくる
あまりも 2万ヒットだったら
これはもうやりきれんだから
腕時計とかまた別な単語を入れたってとかね
ネット販売とかって入れちゃうと
ネット販売と腕時計両方入っているページが少なくなってくる
それ自分必要なものを選んだりするでしょうし
それで回向する場合 そちらの逆の機能するんですよ
ご先祖が功徳を受けますようにと言うと
もうものすごい幅広いんです
ものすごい幅広い 当然自分の父親も入っている
父親のことを心配してやっているのは当たり前
しかし あげる場合はワイルドカードシステムであげるんです
なぜそんなことをするのかというと
もう無双にご先祖様がいるんだから
この功徳を受けられるところにもたくさんいるんです
そちらにもOKです だから仏教的に回向すると必ず供養を受けるんだと
誰かが一人二人ではないんですけどね
ということで 仏教はコンビ